[Música]
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump podría ser demandado por su papel
en el asalto al Capitolio de enero de
2021 así lo informó el departamento de
Justicia que indicó que el exmandatario
no tiene inmunidad absoluta ante las
demandas civiles presentadas por
policías e integrantes del congreso
fue publicada la polémica reforma
electoral del gobierno de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador en el diario oficial de
México la normativa ha suscitado
multitudinarias protestas en el país
pidiendo su derogación porque reduce la
financiación y personal del Instituto
Nacional electoral
inicio en Panamá la conferencia
nuestros océanos el evento congrega a
gobiernos de todo el mundo empresarios y
miembros de la sociedad civil para
pactar compromisos que ayuden a proteger
los océanos
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque por primera vez el
departamento de Justicia Indicó que el
expresidente Donald Trump puede ser
demandado por su papel en el asalto al
Capitolio se trata de un documento de la
división de derechos civil que expone
que Trump no tiene inmunidad absoluta
ante las demandas civiles presentadas
por policías y por miembros del Congreso
que lo consideran responsable de daños
físicos y psicológicos Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió
desde la capital estadounidense
oficiales de la policía del Capitolio
junto con 11 miembros demócratas de la
cámara de representantes buscan
responsabilizar a Trump por las lesiones
físicas y psicológicas que sufrieron
Durante los disturbios del seis de enero
del 2021 cuando simpatizantes de Donald
Trump Se tomaron el Capitolio la demanda
fue presentada en virtud del estatuto
redactado después de la guerra civil
estadounidense respuesta al un plan que
permite indemnizaciones por daños o
perjuicios cuando se utiliza la fuerza
las amenazas o la intimidación para
impedir que los funcionarios del
gobierno lleven a cabo sus funciones en
respuesta Trump argumentado que está
protegido de esta demanda por la
inmunidad absoluta conferida a un
presidente que desempeña sus funciones
oficiales sin embargo departamento de
Justicia instó al tribunal de
apelaciones a rechazar las afirmaciones
generales de inmunidad presidencial
presentadas por el expresidente Trump en
el litigio civil en torno a la
insurrección del seis de enero del 2021
cabe Resaltar que esta es la primera vez
que el departamento de Justicia se
refiere directamente a la cuestión de
inmunidad civil de Trump por su conducta
relacionada al 6 de enero
pasamos a noticias de México fue
publicada en el diario oficial la
controvertida reforma electoral que fue
impulsada por el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador de esta manera el
llamado Plan B entró en vigor y entre
los cambios establecidos está el despido
del que hasta el jueves era el
secretario ejecutivo del Instituto
Nacional electoral INE previamente
conversamos con Mario carbonel
corresponsal en Ciudad de México que nos
dijo que otros cambios al poder
electoral impone esta reforma del
gobierno y con qué objetivo
fundamentalmente lo que busca es una
reestructura del instituto con el
argumento de acuerdo con los autores de
la iniciativa El presidente y sus
partidos de generar ahorros de evitar
que se derroche el dinero de una
política de austeridad sin embargo lo
que Argumenta la autoridad electoral
actual es que uno de los aspectos más
preocupantes es que en esta reestructura
desaparece las trescientas juntas
distritales cada cada junta estaba
integrada por cinco vocales que pues se
dedicaban a organizar el proceso
electoral No nada más en en época de
elecciones sino durante permanentemente
es decir dónde se van a ubicar las
casillas el listado nominal y ahora con
la Reforma en lugar de estos cinco
vocales habrá un solo vocal operativo en
estos que serán ahora órganos auxiliares
esto a juicio de el presidente del INE
es dinamitar al instituto es destazar al
INE y poner en riesgo la certeza de lo
que Hasta ahora ha hecho de manera
integral el Instituto en Panamá inició
la octava versión de la conferencia
mundial sobre los océanos oceans con
llamados a una mayor transparencia en
políticas de protección y medidas
concretas contra la contaminación por
plástico justamente Esta es una de las
principales problemáticas ambientales
que vive Panamá y las aguas servidas uno
de los principales focos litros de agua
sucia corren diariamente porquebradas
que tienen como destino el océano
Pacífico el informe es de nuestro
corresponsal Oscar zurbarán
al día en esta quebrada aledaña a una
pequeña Urbanización a 30 kilómetros de
la capital panameña es parte del sistema
fluvial que termina en el océano
Pacífico en el lugar existe una planta
de tratamiento que nunca funcionó
[Música]
según Magda esta situación se repite en
otras 87 urbanizaciones cercanas al
lugar de la provincia de Panamá oeste
nos preocupa Pues que estamos
contaminando no solamente esa quebrada
estamos contaminando el río aguacate al
final y al final el mar y cuántos años
ya llevamos más de 12 años en esto
estas tuberías en el agua sucia de las
casas el lugar donde terminan es este
río que ha cambiado su aspecto en las
últimas décadas según Comenta benigno
vecino del lugar por más de 50 años
el río estaba bonito todo limpia vos
limpia agua que se podía bañar todo el
mundo ya digo te apoyan hasta pescar lo
que quisiera por ahí camarones de todo y
eso pero qué va a medir el tiempo fue
avanzando
añadiéndose tantas
Barriada tanta más gente y más gente
creciendo la comunidad el pueblo la
población Así mismo Claro que todo eso
va llegando a donde al solamente al río
es el único que hay son miles de litros
de agua permanente que corren y terminan
afectando el ecosistema Marino
principalmente los corales Carolina que
forma parte de un equipo científico del
smithsonian Investiga el impacto de las
aguas servidas
no todas las zonas tienen corrientes que
puedan que hacer que estas aguas se
mezclen y se combinen con agua fresca
que no que te que tengan una baja
descarga de O sea que tenga pocos
nutrientes Entonces
si no es una zona que hay un gran
movimiento de agua ya sea por viento o
por corrientes o si es una Bahía
semicerrada estos estanca la
contaminación de las aguas son parte de
los 19 problemas ambientales directos
que ha identificado el Ministerio de
ambiente de Panamá en la actualidad se
ejecuta un proyecto de saneamiento de la
Bahía de Panamá que garantizaría su
limpieza total en 2050 para evitar que
la contaminación urbana llegue a los
océanos
el presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva conversó en una
videollamada con su homólogo ucraniano
vuelo de mirt selenski Lula le reitero
su intención de trabajar en iniciativas
para poner fin al conflicto el
mandatario brasileño dijo que conversará
con los líderes de otras naciones para
que participen en iniciativas en torno
al diálogo y la paz la conversación
confirma lo anunciado por selens quien
el primer aniversario de la guerra
cuando Indicó que quería acercarse
América Latina para que la región
entienda lo que está ocurriendo en
Ucrania
me he reunido por video con el
presidente de Ucrania zelensky reafirme
el deseo de Brasil de hablar con otros
países y participar en cualquier
iniciativa en torno a la construcción de
la paz y el diálogo la guerra no puede
interesar a nadie en Argentina un
supermercado perteneciente a la familia
de Antonela roccuzzo modelo e influencer
esposa del futbolista Leonel Messi
recibió múltiples disparos el miércoles
por la noche los asaltantes dejaron una
nota en la que amenazaban al Astro
argentino y catalogaban al alcalde de la
ciudad de Rosario como narcotraficante
El presidente Alberto Fernández condenó
los hechos y se comprometió a luchar
contra el crimen organizado
Messi Te estamos esperando era el
mensaje que se leía frente a un
supermercado de la familia de Antonela
rocuso la esposa del futbolista
argentino Lionel Messi el local ubicado
en la ciudad de Rosario fue alcanzado
por 14 balas disparadas por dos hombres
armados que se movilizaban en una
motocicleta el hecho fue condenado por
el propio presidente argentino Alberto
Fernández
hoy amanecí
con una noticia fea en Rosario donde
habían baleado un supermercado
me comuniqué enseguida con el intendente
hablé enseguida con el jefe de gabinete
le dije pongámonos en marcha ya para ver
algo además habrá que hacer estamos
haciendo mucho pero evidentemente algo
más habrá que hacer lo que los que
tienen armas la nota también hacía
referencia al alcalde de la ciudad Pablo
Hawking aquí en catalogaban de
narcotraficante El funcionario culpó a
las fuerzas de seguridad por no combatir
de manera efectiva el crimen organizado
unas declaraciones que fueron
contestadas por el ministro de seguridad
Aníbal Fernández y si yo le digo que
hace 20 años que están en esta situación
Usted cree que no han ganado han ganado
Ahora hay que revertirla nosotros
estamos dispuestos a revertirla Sí
nosotros Nosotros sí Seguro que sí
Rosario en donde nació Lionel Messi y
dio sus primeros golpes a la pelota es
la tercera ciudad más grande de
Argentina una que en los últimos años se
ha visto azotada por el narcotráfico y
que ha visto aumentar sus índices de
violencia la urbe presentó más de 280
homicidios en 2022 una cifras que no
tiene ninguna otra ciudad del país
frente al informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]